j'ai raconté mon histoire à jean-rachide
et j'en Rachid on se connaît depuis
comme tous les trois on se connaît
depuis plus de 20 ans mais c'est marrant
d'être à la télé avant
et j'en rajoute à tout de suite dit oui
il m'a tout de suite dit il faut que tu
racontes un film qui qui parle de toi
qui qui est un peu inspiratoire et quand
je racontais mon histoire je suis un peu
mieux hein tu m'as eu parce que là je
suis pas un truc mais voilà moi quand
j'arrive en France j'étais un enfant
hospitalisé pendant 7 ans à l'hôpital
Necker et pendant l'hospitalisation j'ai
rencontré ces clous là qui me faisait
rire qui faisait rire mes parents et je
me suis dit et puis plus tard quand je
suis devenu bouder comédien j'allais moi
voir les enfants dans les hôpitaux j'ai
recroisé ses clous là et je voulais leur
rendre hommage à eux à toute personne de
l'Hospitalier qui grâce à eux je suis là
aujourd'hui parce que il faut un travail
exceptionnel des infirmières les
infirmiers les docteurs et je voulais
moi seul truc que je sais faire c'est
faire rire et écrire des trucs et j'en
ai parlé à Jean Rachid et j'en Rachid à
tout de suite dit oui et il m'a dit
cette phrase il m'a dit si ça marche
on va être heureux si ça marche pas on
sera heureux quand même parce qu'on aura
fait le film qu'on voulait le film
touchant et drôle voilà donc ça sort
demain
producteur du film voilà qui va pouvoir
s'acheter d'autres sweat bientôt
non c'est vrai que ils m'en parlent
depuis très longtemps de ce film et
c'est vrai que Buder il a une histoire
incroyable et c'est vrai que la vie de
bouder Cédric bouder voilà tu as pas été
facile pour toi non mais moi je vis ma
deuxième vie parce que exactement quand
je suis arrivé au monde en août 78 au
Maroc dans un petit village je suis né
avec des complications de respiration et
le docteur du village qui à l'époque
était aussi électricien
il a été en plus c'était vétérinaire
aussi
donc voilà elle a dit à ma mère cet
enfant ne passera pas l'hiver il
dépassera pas le mois de décembre mon
papa était ici j'ai pas drôle ça
et mon papa était ici en France il a dit
non on va le soigner je suis arrivé à
l'hôpital Necker je suis resté pendant 7
ans en 13 sorti et voilà et je me suis
soigné et comme on a coutume de dire
faut pas oublier d'où on vient moi je
viens de l'hôpital Necker et j'en suis
très fier et je voilà c'est un appel à
tous ceux qui sont dans les hôpitaux
croyez en vous et je suis avec vous
force à vous et merci à toi Cyril parce
que tu as quand même aidé ce film là à
se financer grâce à Canal+ ça il faut le
dire faut dire des choses merci parce
que Guillaume j'en avais parlé il y a
quoi 3 ans 3 ans j'avais parlé de ce
film là il m'a dit franchement tu es tu
tiens un vrai truc soit naturel